[موسيقى]
اخافوهم من اجسادهم للصغير قالوا لا تسمح
لبني ادم ان يمس جسدك وللصغيره قالوا شرفك
بين رجليك فحافظي عليه وصنيه قالوا لهم
احذروا الاغتصاب
لكنهم لم يقولوا لهم لا تغتصبوا لم يقولوا
ان وفي اي علاقه جنسيه كلا لا يمكن ان
تعني نعم وان كل ما يخرج عن الرضائيه هو
جريمه والجريمه لا تبرر والتضامن لا يمكن
ان يكون الا مع الضحيه ثقافه الاغتصاب في
فلك الممنوع
تنورتها قصيره جدا هل رايت احمر شفاهيها
سلوكها مثير تحاول جذب كل الرجال يبدو
انها كانت تحت تاثير الخمر
ذهبت معه الى شقته بمحض ارادتها او تقول
لا بعد ان قالت نعم تستحق ما حصل لها
ثقافه الاغتصاب هي مجموعه من المعتقدات
السائده تبرر الاعتداء الجنسي او تشجعه
احيانا فتكرس العنف ضد المراه او تلومها
لتقلب الحقائق تصبح الضحيه مذنبه واثمه
ويتم التشير بها ويقلل من وقع الجريمه
واثارها
يعود اول استعمال لثقافه الاغتصاب الى
كتاب جماعي نشر عام 74 في الولايات
المتحده وعنوانه الاغتصاب الكتاب المرجعي
الاول للمراه وفي السنه التي تلت سيصبح
المصطلح اكثر تداولا على المستوى العالمي
وذلك بفضل فيلم وثائقي عنوانه ثقافه
الاغتصاب لكن تداول هذا المفهوم لم يحسن
الخلافه الاكاديمي حوله اذ تعتبر الكاتب
والنسويه ان الافكار المسبقه عن العنف
الجنسي والمغتصبين والضحايا تنتقل من جيل
الى جيل وتتطور بمرور الوقت لتتغلغل في
المجتمع باسره فستحول الى ثقافه اغتصاب
فيما يرد عليها عالم الاجتماع الفرنسي
قائلا تعبير الثقافه الاغتصاب هو سلاح
للنطال اكثر من كونه مفهوما اكاديميا
مفهوم اكاديمي او مصطلح للنضال لم يحسم
الجدل بعد الا ان في التاريخ المعاصر
امثله متعدده تقلل من واقع الاغتصاب
كجريمه وتكرس التطبيع معه ففي قال احد
البرلمانيين الاسبان القوانين كالنساء
وجدت الاغتصابها على الضفه الثانيه في
العالم العربي تكثر الامثله ايضا اخرها
كانت قضيه الفنان المغربي سعد المجرد فبعد
ان حكم عليه بالسجن ست سنوات لاداناته
باختصاب بشابه فرنسيه وضربها في فندق
بالعاصمه باريس في اكتوبر 2016 لم يرق
الحكم لشريحه غير بسيطه من جمهوره شريحه
لم تخجل من مساندته بل ذهبت الى حد شتم
ناجي منه ووصفها بابشع النعوت فهي التي
رافقت الى غرفته في الفندق وهي التي تبرجت
بشكل مثير وهي التي تتعمد ابتزازه وتشويها
صورته فهل ولدت من ترفض علاقه مع المعلم
حبيب الجماهير افكار تنتشر في الوعي
الجمعي الذي يعتبر ان جرائم الاغتصاب لا
تحدث الا في موقف سيارات مظلم او في زقاق
خالي من الماره وان المغتصب غالبا ما يكون
مجرما غريبا مقنعا يحمل سكينا لكن الواقع
هو عكس ذلك تشير الارقام الى ان اغلب
الناجيات هنا على معرفه سابقه بالجانب
فلماذا هناك من يشكك برواياتهم وما الذي
يدفع البعض الى التبريد لهذه الجرائم
[موسيقى]
في فلك الممنوع عن ثقافه الاغتصاب قبل
البدايه اود ان اشير الى اننا وخلال
الاعداد لهذه الحلقه تواصلنا مع العديد من
الناجيات من جرائم اغتصاب دون ان يقبلنا
بالادلاء بشهادتهن فغالبيتهن لم يرغبن
باعاده تذكر بشاعه ما تعرضنا له وفضلنا
التزام الصمت
ابدا من بيروت مع الصحفيه المتخصصه في
شؤون الفنيه رولا نصر اهلا بك رولا قبل ان
اسالك اود ان اشير فقط للمشاهدات
والمشاهدين الى اننا وخلال هذه الحلقه قد
نتطرق للعديد من القضايا التي تعني بعض
المشاهير او التي اشتهرت فيما يتعلق
بالاغتصاب منها قضيه الفنان سعد لمجرد وان
الهدف من الحديث عن هذه القضيه ليس محاكمه
او اعاده محاكمه هذا الشخص وانما لانني
لست قاضيه طبعا ولا عامله في المجال
القانوني واننا انما كون هذه القضيه خلقت
نوع من الانقسام في الراي العام رولا اوجد
الترحيب بك انت كنت من المدافعين عن سعد
المجرد كيف يمكن اليوم لسيده ان تتعاطف مع
رجل متهم بالاختصاب لا مع ضحيه هذا الشخص
بس للتوضيح بسيط انه انا لا ادافع عن
المغتصب انا طرحت اسئله انه ممكن هذا
الشخص يكون بريء لانه ما حدا له حقي حاكم
شخص من دون دليل
حكم بست سنوات وهو الحكم منه مبرم منه
نهائي هو عنده فرصه الاستئناف كما وانه من
بعد الاستئناف هو طبعا ممكن يلجا لمحكمه
النقد في حال كان حكمه الاستئناف كمان لا
يرضيه فنحن يعني القانون الدولي المتعارف
عليه انه المتهم بريء حتى تثبت اذنته لحد
هيدي اللحظه ما كان في ادله دامغه وسابته
ميه بالميه لحتى نحن نقول انه سعد لمجرد
مختصب في حال هو كان مغتصب طبعا يستحق اشد
العقوبات وانا رح كون اول وحده بتحكي بهذا
الموضوع ولكن طالما انه لحد اللحظه ما في
ادله دامغه وثابته عليه هو له حق انه كمان
يدافع عن نفسه لانه ممكن يطلع بريء او
مظلوم او ضحيه مكيده دبرت له شو الاسباب
ما بنعرف طبعا يعني لكن غالبا سيدتي غالبا
يعني في الفطره كبشر لدينا ميل الى ان
نتعاطف مع الضحيه يعني واليوم المحكمه في
فرنسا حكمت عليه بست سنوات سجن بتهمه
الاغتصاب انت يعني هذا التشكيك من اين
ياتي لماذا نحن لا نتعاطف مع الضحيه بشكل
تلقائي او او فطري
حضرتك سالتي وجاوبتي بشكل فطري وتلقائي
نحن على طول نتعاطف مع الضحيه في حال كانت
ضحيه ولكن حسب مجريات المحاكمه لسعد لمجرد
لورا الضحيه كمان كان في عندها اكثر من
روايه بناقضوا بعضهم والاهم ما في
بالموضوع انه تقرير الطب الشرعي ما اثبت
انه
الاختصاب وما كان في ولا اي اثر دعينا لا
ندخل في التفاصيل لانه الهدف هو اليوم ان
نفهم فقط كيف يمكن ان يكون هناك انقسام في
الراي حول مساله يعني حول جريمه اغتصاب
كيف يمكن اليوم ان نصل الى وساسال يعني في
هذا الخصوص ساعود الي ك سيدتي الضيفه
الثانيه من لندن صحفيه والناشطه النسويه
زينه رحيم زينه اهلا بك كيف تقربين انت
هذا الانقسام في الراي وهل تربطينه بما
بات يعرف اليوم بثقافه الاغتصاب
بالتاكيد اولا مرحبا جميعا
التشكيك التشكيك حتى بقضاء يعتبر قضاء
نزيه بمحكمه بالتاكيد لم تبني قرار
بالادانه على
شكوك او على مواضيع غير مثبته فنحن قبل
الادانه رغم وجود عده شهادات وشهادات يعني
اتجاه نفس هذا الشخص كان انه ما في قرار
محكمه وعندنا مصادر قرار المحكمه لسه
بنقول يمكن يستانف يمكن يطلع للنقد في حال
كانت اي جريمه اخرى لا تتعلق بالنساء ما
كنا تصرفنا بهذه الطريقه وهذا اللي بيصب
بالنهايه بموضوع ثقافه الاغتصاب وبالتبرير
بالتاكيد هناك موضوع تقاطعي المكان
الاجتماعي للشخص الشهره المحبوبيه وحتى
ايضا الشكل كلها بتساهم بزياده التعاطف
مثل ما ذكر التقرير لانه بذهننا جريمه
الاغتصاب يجب ان تكون بظروف معينه والضحيه
لها شكل معين طيب نتعرف على الضيفه
الرابعه الثالثه عفوا من الدار البيضاء من
كازابلانكا ريما كراش اهلا بك
من الرباط عفوا ريما كراج اهلا بك انت
متخصصه في علم النفس في وحده الاستماع
والدعم النفسي لحركه خارجات عن القانون
يعني في فيما يتعلق بهذه القضايا قضايا
الاغتصاب اليوم هل تعتبرين ان مجتمعات
التي نعيش فيها في العالم العربي مجتمعات
ايضا ترزخ تحت ما يسمى بثقافه الاغتصاب
ولماذا نعم اكيد لان ثقافه الاغتصاب هي
مفاهيم اللي مترسخه في المجتمعات ماشي غير
المجتمعات العربيه من مجتمعات الدول
المتقدمه كذلك وهي متوارثه معنى ديال
ثقافه الاغتصاب هي تشكيك النفاش الضحيه او
الناجيه كتقدم شكوى كنرجعوها هي اللي
خاطئه كيفاش كانت لابسه اشنو دارت كنقلبوا
في الماضي ديالها دوك الورك هذا الشيء ما
كنديروش فاش كيكونوا جرائم اخرى انا
قرينه البراءه حق ولكن ما كنهضروش على
قرينه البراءه في جرائم اخرى من غير
الاغتصاب ومن غير من غير العنف الجنسيه
داكشي علاش خصنا نفهمه بان هاد العقليه
الذكوريه سامه ما كنقولش بان الرجال
كاملين عندهم هاد العقليه ولكن
الوعي بحقوق المراه
مع مشاهير يعني
واشرف حكيمي وامثله اخرى ليس فقط الرجال
كما قلت نعم لان الناس فاش كانسولهم بان
اشنو هما الراي ديالهم على الاغتصاب او
العنف الجنسي بطريقه عامه كيقولوا بانهم
غير متفقين وان بالنسبه لهم جريمه ولكن
فاش كتوقع قضيه اغتصاب كيولي بالنسبه لهم
رايي ان كل واحد كيعطي الراي دياله
الاغتصاب جريمه ليس رايه خدمت معاه كجريمه
وندينها كجريمه اما انا فاش كنقولوا بان
الناس كاملين كيعرفوا الناجيات او الضحايا
ولكن كيكون شي واحد قريب ولا شي واحد
مشهوره بالنسبه لهم هذاك غير مختصبوا له
تبريرات هذه هي ثقافه وصلت الفكره طيب
نتعرف هنا في الاستوديو على الطبيب
المتخصص في علم الاعصاب الادراكي البرم
خيبر اهلا بك اريد ان اسال اليوم عندما
تحدثت منذ قليل ريم عن مساله انه الضحيه
ضحيه او الناجيه من اغتصاب غالبا في الراي
العام نسال هل ذهبت معه الى شقته ماذا
كانت ترتدي هل اغرته
لماذا هناك من يبحث اليوم عن مبررات
لمغتصب او لجريمه اغتصاب كيف يفسر هذا
الامر او هل يفسر في علم النفس يفسر من
خلال ثقافه
الاغتساب والذكريه انه
بنسميه هذا بدنا نلاقي لون الضحيه على ليش
هيك صار بين مواطنطلع على الارقام بنلاحظ
انهم هيدا شي منسميه بالانجليزي
[موسيقى]
من امن فيها لولا سبب لانه من حصه مزبوطه
ليست علميه وبنعرف اليوم انه اكثريه
الضحايا تبع الاغتصاب ما بيكون خصهم مرات
كتير من شخص من العيله من حدا معروف ان
نحن هلا عم نحكي عن عن حالات اغتصاب
لمشاهير بس هيدا هيدا الطرقات مع التعامل
من الايام داخل عائلات بجروب اصحاب منه شي
متخصص بس يعني نحن عم نشوف انجا واحد صفر
فاصله صفر واحد من هالحالات الحالات بيكون
مش شخص ما بنعرفه عم يمشي قصير بالشارع
بيكون شخص من المجتمع تبعنا
بطاقه بيضاء للرجل او كارت بلونش كما يقال
لكي يسمح بارتكاب هذه الجريمه ما بعرف اذا
فينا نقول انه بس اكيد بصير في اقل
ردع لانه عارفين عم نشوف انه بتصير وبعدين
كنا عم نحكي عن الادل كتير مهم بحالات
الاغتصاب انه كتير صعب حدا يكون عنده ادله
انه انا اذا كنت حدا عم يتعدى
يكون موائع وين ما معقول يكون في هناك
الاثر العلمي ايضا اذا ما قامت قام الشخص
المعتدى علي بالذهاب الى المستشفى
على شخص عاش جريمه انه بده يكون عنده
الوعي النفسي تنهار بدل ما يكون يهتم
بحاله يكون عطلانها انه انا لازم اروح على
المستشفى
وراح على البوليس وعلى التقرير بين هالشخص
مدمر لانه صار عليه اعتداء جسده وهو بده
يقول لا لا انا هلا بدي يوصل لعنا
بالعيادات اشخاص مرات بيكون اغتصاب صار له
اسابيع اشهر مرات السنين لانه اول في حاله
خجل في كثير اسباب نفسيه بتخلي انه مش متل
كانه حدا ضربني وبروح دغري في اعتداء على
على
الشخص وحرمه الجسديه حرمه على الحرمه تبع
الشخص هذا الشيء وهنا بنشوف
العلم لانه القانون بيقول بريء لحتى يطهر
لحتى نسبه ادانته بينما بدنا ادله بس نحن
هون على جرائم 3/4 الوقت مستحيل يكون في
دليل من ورا طبع الجريمه طيب نتعرف على
ضيفنا الاخير في الاستوديو ايضا مدير
التواصل والمرافعه في قسم الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا التابعه لمنظمه اهلا بك
احمد بن شمسي
احمد اليوم يعني من بعد هذا الحديث عن
ثقافه الاغتصاب التعريف القانوني للاغتصاب
ما هو
وهل يخدم الناجيات في مكان ما ام كما تفضل
وقال قانونيا اليوم من الصعب جدا ان نثبت
في حال ضحيه لم تقم باجراء الفحوص بشكل
مباشر بعد الاعتداء هناك اظن خلط منهجي
بين مفهوم ان الاغتصاب يعرف بالجنس بالقوه
حينما الاغتصاب تعريفه القانوني ليس هو
الجنس بالقوه هو الجنس بدون التراضي يعني
الجنس بدون موافقه فليس من الضروري ان
تمارس القوه يمكن ان تكون هناك ظروف
مختلفه ومتعدده حيث تحس المراه بان تم
اضطرارها الى ممارسه الجنس بدون ممارسه
القوه فلذلك هذا المفهوم ان
لازم ان تكون هناك يعني ادله دامغه ماديه
طبيه انه تمت ممارسه القوه على هذه المراه
او انها حاولت الفرار او انها كان هناك
عراك بينها وبين المغتصم ليس هناك اثر
جسدي ليس هناك عنف يعني احيانا عنف ان
يكون عنف لكن يمكن كذلك ان يكون عنف معنوي
يمكن يكون خداع حيله ضغط يمكن ان تكون
ضحيه لشخص هو
يراسك في العمل او عند سلطه معنويه يعني
عليك يمكن ان حتى ان لا تكن كل هذه هل
يلحق القانون اليوم او الانظمه القانونيه
في الدول التي تعمل على هذه الملفات يعني
بشكل جدي هل يلحق هذا النوع من التعريفات
اليوم هل طبعا يلحق هذه التعليقات يعني
الطريقه السليمه
لتناول هذه القضايا هي الفحص الدقيق في
الظروف ما هي الظروف لان تعريف مره اخرى
الاغتصاب هو الجنس بدون موافقه فالموافقه
يمكن ان تعطى ويمكن ان ترفع اذن هناك مشكل
في تعريف المفاهيم لدى الراي العام اليوم
الناس ربما يعني ليس العنف فقط هو عدم
موافقه بل اكثر من ذلك يمكن ان تعطى
الموافقه وان تسحب الموافقه لان من حق اي
شخص سواء كان رجل ام امراه ان يغير ان
يغير
يعني العمليه الجنسيه يمكن ان نكون راضيا
وفي وقت من الاوقات ترى ان الوضعيه ليست
مناسبه للسبب او سبب ما لاننا كلنا بشر
يمكن ان نغير راينا فتغير رايها وهذا لا
يبرر ابدا ان تتواصل العمليه الجنسيه لان
للمراه والرجل كذلك للمناسبه الحق في ان
يوقف العمليات في اي لحظه فلذلك هذا الخط
الظروف الذي تفضلت به يعني اننا نفترض
اليوم عن الاغتصاب هو شيء يحدث بالقوه ليس
هذا الخلت هل هو ناتج عن هذه الثقافه التي
اليوم تسمى بثقافه الاغتصاب ام كيف ثقافه
الاغتصاب يعني تنسب للثقافه بصفه عامه
وكذلك تكلم عن بعض المجتمعات التي لديها
غالبا ما نفكر في المجتمعات العربيه او
المسلمه اولا هذا مفهوم خطا لان ثقافه
الاغتصاب هي شائعه هي تقافه ذكوريه
والذكريه ليس حكر للعرب هي موجوده في سائر
دول العالم لكن عوض التحدث عن ثقافه
الاغتصاب افضل فيما يخصني لان انا كمدافع
عن حقوق الانسان التحدث عن ثقافه افلات
المغتصبين من العقاب وهذا ليس فقط مساله
ثقافه بل هو مساله
انظمه وقوانين هناك يعني
عدد من القوانين التي تكرس تلك الثقافه
الذكوريه مثلا قانون تجريم العلاقات
الجنسيه الرضائيه بين البالغين خارج
الزواج عندما تكون مراه ضحيه للاغتصاب او
الاعتداء جنسي فتتردد 100 مره قبل ان تبلغ
عن الاعتداء لان اذا كانت في وضعيه حيث لا
يعني لا يتم تصديقها فتصبح مذنبه مثابه
يعني تبلغها يعتبر بمثابه اعتراف
بارتكابها لعمليه هي مجربه اصلا فاذا حملت
فهذا دليل انها قامت بتلك العمليه اذا
القانون اصلا يرضع المراه عن التبليغ عن
الاعتداء الجنسي يلزمها اكثر على يعني
المحافظه على صمتها او على وهذا قانون من
ضمن القوانين هناك كذلك عدم عدم الاغتصاب
الزوجي لان القانون يعتبر ان يعني علاقه
الزوجيه هي علاقه تعطي حق للرجل لممارسه
الجنس مع زوجته وان للزوجه ليس لديها الحق
ان ترفض
ولها واجب الطاعه فان رفضت فهي عاصيه فكل
وجود هذه القوانين يكرس فكره ان للرجل حق
في الجنس وان للمراه عندما ترفض ممارسه
الجنس فهي اصلا مذنبه اللهم ان كان هناك
عنف كل هذه المفاهيم غالطه خطا طيب شكرا
احمد سنشاهد كيف تقارب عينه من المواطنات
والمواطنين في بعض العواصم العربيه جرائم
الاغتصاب نستمع معا
نقول له لا قدر الله ان شاء الله توصل
الجيل الحاله الحد من فميتك تعرف تتحس شنو
هو يحس غيرك شنو تحس بنات الناس لكن في
ملف اشرف حكيمي وصعد المجرد لنترك القضاء
يعني يشتغل يعني ويصدر حكمه يعني هو اللي
يدافع عن جريمه الاغتصاب يدافع عن المختصب
هو هذا لازم يتعاقب وهالدفع عن شخص عمل
كده في حد من اهلك انا شخصيا نشر ان هنالك
نوع من التلفيق والتشويه يستهدف هؤلاء
الاسنان
يطبق عليها الاعداء الشرف ده بيكون حاجه
مهمه جدا وما ينفعش حد يمسقها مهما كان
مين ما يلزمش اي انسان بنحبه معناها
نكسروه او نحطبوه لا قولوا التهمه هذه لا
طبعا جريمه لا تختفر لازم بيبقى فيه حكم
راضع وعاجل طبعا كل قانون ادى الى ان تكون
هذه الجرائم جرائم كبيره ومستفحله في
المجتمع تبريرها هو فاعل قبيح يواجه فعل
الاختصاب
رولا نصر من بيروت صحفيه ولا نصر اريد ان
اسالك اليوم هناك اشكاليه ايضا مطروحه
نسويات غالبا والحقوقيات والحقوقيون
انطلقوا بمبدا نصدق الناجيات هل توافقين
اليوم ان الناجيه من اي عمليه عنف بناء
على النقاش الذي دار منذ قليل بينها كافه
الضيوف يجب ان نصدقها بدون بغض النظر عن
البحث عن ادله خاصه في مساله الاغتصاب
والاعتداء والانتهاك الجنسي اكيد لا لانه
شهدنا يعني بكثير فترات وباكثر من بلد صار
في اتهامات لاشخاص اتهموا بالاغتصاب وبعد
سنوات اتضح انه هن ابرياء يعني اخر قضيه
انحكى فيها بالاعلام قضيه الشاب
البريطانيه اليانور ويليامز ياللي اتهمت
عده اشخاص باداره بالمتاجره بالبشر
وبالاغتصاب وبتهم اخرى حكم عليها القضاء
البريطاني بثمان سنوات سجن لانه تبين انه
هي كانت عم تكذب
قضيه اليانور والامثله اللي ذكرتها هلا
يعني
يريد ان يقول شيئا
ادله راح يتطبق على الفريقين بس الفرق هو
انه في شيء بنسميه بالفرنسي قسيمه
لواحد يقدر يقول هالشي مش نفس الشيء يعني
وقتها تيجي تقول انه هي اغتصبت ويكون عن
كذب عندك كمان صوره تبعها الاجتماعيه مثل
ما كنا عم نحكي هديك الساعه
التشويه بسيطه يعني ما في
اصلا تتحول تلقين متهمة يعني او مذنبه
وبعدين في كتير اشخاص راح يطبوا عليها
الرجل يعني ما فينا ما فينا نتعامل بنفس
الطريقه بامكان عم نقول يعني مين مصدق مين
ما بنصدق بالاخر هو تفكير احتمال يعني بس
الفرق هو نرجع نتطلع على الارقام عنا كتير
اكتر ضحايا لا يصدقوا من ضحايا يصدقوا عن
كذب ومنو حتى قريب يعني الارقام وتنطلع
على الاف والاف
استثناءات ضئيله ضئيله
السؤال لازم ناخده
كمجتمع هل نحن بنقبل انه يكون في عدد ضئيل
جدا للاشخاص عم يتهموا عن زور يلي بينعدوا
يمكن على عيد الاسبوع الوحده قام هل نحن
بنقبل نكمل
بنظام عم بخلي اكثر يتضحايا
ضحيه ولا اشخاص يلي ارتكبوا الجرايم
فلتنين
[موسيقى]
احمد توافق كتير خصوصا فيما يخص المقاربه
يعني
ستاتيستيك الاحصائيه لكن هناك كذلك مقاربه
لفظيه لان يعني اولا مفهوم تصديق الناجيات
لا افهم كيف لا يمكن ان نصدق الناجيات لان
اذا كانت ناجيه يعني ان العداله ثبتت ان
تم اغتصابها فلذلك من الواجب تص لا هناك
العباره هي تصديق النساء مش الناجيات
والاشكاليه هنا ان الكثير ياخذ هذه
العباره في يعني بطريقه يعني يعني ان
امراه لا يمكنها ان تكذب حرفيا حرفيا نعم
يعني ان المراه لا يمكنها ان تكذب او ان
تنفقتهما طبعا ليس صحيح لان المراه مثل
الرجل الحقوق الانسان لكن العباره لا تعني
هذا هي يجب اخذها بالطريقه يعني مزاجيه
وهذا يعني ان هناك واجب للدفع ضد الوضع
السائد والوضع السائد هو الوضع الذي يشخص
احصائيا كما قال البيه وهو وضع يرتكز
اساسا على عدم يعني الاستماع الى النساء
وعلى عدم تصديق النساء فهناك يعني بناء
على تصورات ثقافيه شائعه ومجتمعيه شائعه
مثلا عندما تركب المراه السياره مع الرجل
فهي كانت تبحث عن شيء ما عندما
اذا اذا دخلت منه الى غرفه معه الى غرفه
مغلقه فانها كانت قابله اذا تناولت معه
الكحول فانها كانت قابله هناك مفهوم
الرضائيه في هذا المجال مفهوم خاطئ جدا
التصورات الثقافيه والمجتمعيه التي في اخر
المطاف ترسخ منطلق الفكري ان المراه هي
مذنبه وان لا يجب تصديقها لان تصرفاتها
تشير الى انها كانت راضي الواقع ربما يدفع
اتفضل
لذلك يجب تصديق النساء لا يعني يجب لا
يمكن ان يكذب النساء يعني يجب الدفع ضد
الامر السائد الذي ينطلق من عدم تصديقهن
وهذا امر يعني سوسيولوجيا مهم جدا لاننا
يجب ان نصلح عشرات السنين من الظلم ضد
النساء هذه الفكره وهذا الواقع ربما ما
يدفع حركات مثل حركه خرجات عن القانون في
المغرب اليوم الذي تمثلها معنا ريم عكرش
ريم يدفعكم اليوم ربما الى نقاش هذه
المصطلحات مثل مصطلح نصدق الناجيات اليوم
برايك انت ما تفضل به الضيوف هل نحن بحاجه
من اجل ان نفكك ثقافه الاغتصاب ان ربما
نشرح اكثر للناس عن مفاهيم مثل مفهوم
المصدق الناجيات
نعم اكيد لان الناس بزاف ما يفهموهاش
لماذا سنصدق الناجيات وغادي ياخدو حالات
استثنائيه اللي غادي يشرحو بها علاش ما
خصناش مصدقونا نجاه خصنا نعرفو بان امراه
النساء بصفه عامه او الضحايا عنف جنسي او
اغتصاب
كيعيشوا بزاف ديال اللوم بزاف ديال
شيم انهم كنحسوهم بان داروا شي حاجه اللي
خطا اذن فاش هديك الضحيه كتبغي تقدم شكوى
هذيك راه شجاعه ولابد نشجعوها الى ما
صدقناهاش فنحن نساهم في ثقافه الاغتصاب
وافلات المغتصبين من العقوبه لان فاش
كنقولوا فاش النساء ضحايا كيشوفوا بان
وحده قدمت شكوى ولموها الناس وقالوا بانها
هي اللي خاطئه غادي يرجعوا على هذيك
الرغبه في انهم يقدموا شكوى وخاصهم يعيشوا
بالمسؤوليه ان الشخص الذي ارتكب عليهم
جريمه الاغتصاب يكررها دونك حنايا كيفاش
فاش ما تصدقوش النجاه كناخدو هاد لوريس
بان هذاك المختصب غادي يعاودها
نعاقبوه ويقدر يفلت منها حركات خارجه على
القانون كتقول بان هاد المفاهيم خاصهم
نعرفوهم ما هو الاختصاب ما هي الموافقه
والتراضي واكيد انا كنت متافقه مع
انت يعني متخصصه في علم النفس على
المفاهيم على مفاهيم التراضي واريد ان
اسالك عن مساله الاستماع الى الضحايا
اليوم هناك هذا هذا الصمت هناك صعوبه
الحديث لما يعني ورد منذ قليل في النقاش
لاسباب عديده النساء يخفن من التحدث عن
تجاربهن في العلن كيف تقربين هذا الامر في
وحده الاستماع لضحايا العنف الجنسي او
العنف
يعني او او الاغتصاب او ما الى هنالك هل
هل هناك مثلا امور مشتركه بين كل هذه
الضحايا فيما يتعلق بكسر الصمت نعم هناك
الخوف من الاحكام احكام العائله الخوف من
رده الفعل ديال العائله ان الفكره ديال
الشرف للمراه ان المراه وهذه حتى هي ثقافه
الاغتصاب لانه هناك مفاهيم ان المراه بحال
بحال قنبله قابله للانفجار وانها غادي
تكون نهار غادي تحط العائله في واحد
الموقف اللي ما مزيانش كاين من غير خوف
الخوف من الحكم ديال المجتمع الخوف من
الحبس ان هذيك الضحيه او الناجيه فاش غادي
تاخد القرار بتقديم شكوى يقدر دير السجن
حتى هي لان العلاقات الرضاائيه في المغرب
الى مشات وقدمت شكوى والمغتصب ديالها قال
بانها مشات معه وانها دائما نفس الجمل جدا
لون الضحيه غادي يعني انت لو كنت ساسال
عنها
تحسيس على المفاهيم ديال الاغتصاب ديال
الموافقه ديال التراضي ديال اشنو هما
الانعكاسات النفسيه على الضحايا والناجيات
وكذلك عدم تجريم العلاقات الرضائيه باش
نشجعو الناجيات على تقديم شكوى وما يبقوش
الاشخاص المختصبين يفلتوا من العقوبه اذا
ما اشرت اليه الان يعني هو يفتح على نقاش
اخر وهو ان ثقافه الاغتصاب او كسر حجم
الصمت ايضا لدى الضحايا مرتبط بملفات
حقوقيه اخرى وبقوانين اخرى سابدا معك زينه
ارحيم هل توافقين ان ان اليوم من اجل
التخلص من هذه الثقافه من اجل مساعده
الناجيات على على كسر حاجز الصمت والتبليغ
يجب ان نعمل على قوانين ربما في ملفات
حقوقيه اخرى لها علاقه مثلا اشارت ريم الى
مساله العلاقات الرضائيه خارج اطار الزواج
التي تجرم في العديد من الدول ما رايك
المنطقه بشكل رئيسي القوانين ليست يعني
باهمال تظلم النساء او ضحايا اي عنف جنسي
هي يعني متقصده لدينا بعض القوانين بعدد
من الدول منها العراق مثلا تجبر ضحايا
الاغتصاب على الزواج
تم مراجعه هذا القانون في بعض الدول تزوج
من الضحيه
وهي بالتالي تشجع العديد من الاشخاص اللي
بيرفضوا البنات الزواج منهم وبالتالي هو
بيضمن زواجه منها من اجل حمايه الشرف ورد
شخص من ضمن البوكس للعمل وكان عم يحكي عن
الشرف مفهوم الشرع فهو جزء من من ثقافه
الاغتصاب وهو جزء اساسي لهذا موجوده ايضا
شفنا بمصر بخلال الحمله الاخيره لما
صحفيات وناشطات تضامنوا مع ضحايا الاغتصاب
المخرج المتهم بسبع شهادات للاغتصاب اخذ
للمحكمه
واعتبر بانه هنن يتعم الازعاج وبالتالي
حتى مناصرات الضحايا يتعرضن للتجذيب
وللهجوم والعديد من النساء اللي قرروا
انهن يعملوا شكوى وكما ذكر الزميلتي هي
موضوع جدا شجاع وتحدي للوطن وستتحمل نتائج
طول حياتها ورغم ذلك صار في تسريبات لصور
خاصه فيها وصارت هي الاتهام وحتى الان انا
على على تبعي غير عم تطلعلي
متهمه سعد المجرد
تتحداه وتشكره وبتكون الصبيه عامله فيديو
تيك توك ما دخلوا باي شيء اخر
ان تقوم صبيه بشكل خاصه بنى المنطقه بان
تقوم بان تدعي بانها تعرضت للاغتصاب
وتتعرض لكل هذا السياق من اجل ان تحظى
بشهره او من اجل ان موضوع صعب انه يقبل
التصديق ولذلك انا بالنسبه لالي واحد اصدق
الناجيات سواء كان في موضوع قانوني او لا
اثنين كصحفيه سات بنفسي من السياق بغض
النظر اذا كان في اثار للعنف او لا وثالثا
سادعمها بكل سواء قررت انها تشتكي او ما
قررت انها تشتكي وبهذه الطريقه فينا نبلش
بتهديم هاي كلمه ناجيات تعني انها نجت من
يعني من الانتهاك او من الاغتصاب يعني لم
تمت هذه هي الناجيه ولكن ليس بالضروري ان
تكون كل ناجي اليوم مشتكيه للاسف يعني
ليست تكون ناجيه تذهب الى القضاء وتشتكي
طيب رولا رولا النصر بناء على هذا النقاش
الذي جرى اليوم هل تعتبرين ان ربما في
قضايا ما يتعلق بالعنف ازاء النساء يجب ان
نتوقف عن المفاهيم القديمه التي تقول ان
المتهم بريء حتى تثبت ادانته وما الى
هنالك وان نبحث عن مفاهيم اجدد تساعد
النساء على قانونيا واجتماعيا على التخلص
من هذه الهوه الحقوقيه
طبعا هو العنف مرفوض بكل اشكاله سواء كان
اغتصاب ولا ضرب ولا اي شيء ثاني ولا هيدا
العنف مرفوض ضد المراه وضد اي شيء يعني مش
بس المراه ضد اي انسان بالمطلق ولكن انا
اللي ما بحبه بهذا الموضوع انه ما ننجار
هيك ورا العاطفه والغريزه يعني حضرتكم لما
حكيت انا عن موضوع اليانور قلتوا انه هيدي
استثناءات صح بس استثناء كان خرب حياته
ودمر حياه عده اشخاص ثلاثه من المتهمين
الاسيويين يلي انحكى انحكموا بقضيه
اليانور حاولوا الانتحار بالسجن ثلاثه
منهم خسروا كل المصرياتهم فاتوا الناس على
بيوتهم
تتعرضوا
عفوا
يعني مش بالسهل نطلع هيك بنلف خبريه ولازم
حكمه على الاستثناءات على الملايين ربما
من السيدات يعني اجراء الاغتصاب منتشر في
كثير عالم بشكل كبير انا ما عم اقول سلام
الاغتصاب ما بتصير عفوا انا ما عم قول
جرائم الاغتصاب ما بتصير وانه ما لازم
نحاكم المختصب طبعا لا بس انا عم اقول ما
نتاخد تلقائيا بالغريزه نبحث بس شوي على
الوقائع على الدليل على الاثبات بعدين
الحاكموا متل ما نحن بدنا سميتها غريزه
ساسال دكتور البئر ما بعرف يعني هل ما
رايك
اول شيء مثلا عم نحكي عن الشخص اللي اسمه
اليانور الشيل الملفت انه
وقتها بدنا نحكي عن الحالات الاستثنائيه
بنعرف اساميهم بس ما فينا نسمي الضحايا
اغتصاب المجرم تبعهم بعده فلتان يعني كمان
هذا الشخص
خلينا نتعاطف تشخيص مع شخص بينما في اسامي
ملايين وملايين وملايين وما بتخيل حدا منا
في يسمى اسامي ضحايا
نقطه ثاني نقطه عم نركز على حالات اغتصاب
مشاهير انا كعلم نفس الاشخاص بيجوا
بيشوفوني منهم المعروف والمغتصبين تبعهم
منهم المعروفين هن
اكثر الاوقات اشخاص من عائلتهم خالون عمهم
ابن عمهم
اخوهم مرات
الضغط النفسي لحدا يجي يخترع قصه وينبز من
كل عيلته ما راحت عنده اصحاب ما راح عنده
شي بس لانه
ما بدنا نركز على على البعض مره المشاهير
يقدروا هن يخطفوا موضوع اجتماعي كارثه شو
عم يصير القضايا التي تاخذ اليوم حيز كبير
من من النقاش الاعلامي ربما لا تعكس وسهل
نخترع دوافع دوافع نقديه مصاري اما نفوز
انه هالشخص بده يسقط حدا مشهور كرمال هو
ينشه
بينما باكثريه اكثريه الاوقات
الاشخاص مع منهم معروفين منهم عالميين
واخر نقطه بس حاقول عن عن عن ثقافه
الاغتصاب انه هي كانت بتضر على الرجال
لانه بنحكي بس عن ثقافه الاغتصاب
هو مش الموضوع اليوم بس مثلا الاغتصاب
الرجال يتعرضون
اكبر بكثير
عم يغتصبوا الرجل المفروض دايما يكون بده
الجنس كيف يعني حدا اغتصبك مش معقول لازم
كمان نتذكر منا قصه باس انه عم ينضروا
النساء كتير رجال كمان عم ينضروا وانا
بشغله كعالم نفس فسر قديه الذكوريه وهل
ثقافه الاغر الكل الا المغتصب اللي هو
محمل احمد احمد انا اريد ان اعود الى شيء
قلته عندما تذكرتي عن مفهوم المتهم بريء
حتى تثبت ادانته وربما كان كانت تصور ان
ربما هذا المفهوم قد يكون متقادم او
متجاوز او يمكن ان نعيده في لست متفقا
تماما لان يعني مفهوم المساواه امام
القانون ليس متجاوز ولا متقاعد هو مفهوم
اساسي اللي هي توفير العداله كيف ما كان
الحال ففعلا
الجميع متساوي امام العداله وامام القضاء
ويجب ان يكون هناك مساواه امام القانون
امام المحاكم والدليل بالدليل والشهاده
بالشهاده لكن اين هو المشكل هو انا عندما
نقول الشهاده بالشهاده يجب كذلك ان نركز
على ظروف الشهاده عندما يشهد رجل المجتمع
مستعد لتصديقه عندما تشهد امراه هناك
عشرات من الحواجز تجعل من شهادتها صعبه
وشعبه جدا لانها تتعرض الى وصم اجتماعي
تتعرض الى مشاكل ضمن عائلاتها تتعرض ربما
الى طردها من العمل تتعرض الى ملاحقتها
قضائيا في ظل قوانين تجرب العلاقه الجنسيه
الروائيه تتعرض الى الى الى
الزواج بمغتصبها تتعرض الى يعني عواقب
نفسيه مختلفه وكثيره ناتجه عن ضغط المجتمع
تتعرض الى مستقبل قد يتم تشويهه فكل هذا
السياق لا يمكن ان نغض النظر والطرف عنه
فعندما نقول المساواه امام القانون فعلا
لكن بمراعاه ظروف الادله والشهادات من
الادله هذه هي العداله الحقيقيه شكرا لك
احمد ريم عكراش اليوم يعني سؤال ربما يطرح
نفسه هذه القوانين الموجوده في بعض الدول
ربما الكثير من السيدات اليوم المختصبات
يجبرنا في مكان ما على الزواج
بجلادهن بمختصبهن من ناحيه علم النفس هلا
شرحتي للمشاهدات والمشاهدين ماذا يعني هذا
الامر اليوم لسيده ان تتزوج رجلا اغتصبها
التاثيرات النفسيه اللي كتوقع من بعد
جريمه الاغتصاب خاصنا نعرفوا بان هناك
تاثيرات انيه في الوقت ديال الجريمه اللي
يمكن تكون اللي كنسميوها الديسوسياسيون
انها ما كتحسش براسها
كونيكتي لهذاك الوقت ذاك الشيء علاش بزاف
ديال الناس كيقولوا لها وعلاش ما جريتيش
علاش ما مشيتيش علاش ما حميتيش راسك فهذي
حتى واحد ما يقدر يحس بهذاك الشيء اللي
كاتكون فيه ومن بعد كيكونوا اعراض اخرى
ديال اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه اللي يمكن
تسترجع بعض
ويمكن تعيش واحد
القلق والتوتر اللي كبير بزاف فاش كيكون
الاجبار على على الزواج بالمغتصب كنعاودو
نعيشوها نفس الصدمه جميع الاثار وبجميع
الاعراض ديال هاديك اضطراب ما بعد صدمه كل
نهار كانت قضيه في المغرب اللي معروفه
ديال الضحيه ديال الضحيه اغتصاب
اللي دارت محاوله الانتحار حيث العائله
زوجاتها بالمغتصب هذا القانون تحيد في
المغرب ولكن راه باقيين عائله بالزاف اللي
كيبزوا على اللي كيجبروا النساء اللي
تعرضوا الاغتصاب انهم يتزوجوا بالمغتصب
لانها بالنسبه لهم مساله شرف ذاك الشيء
علاش ثقافه الاغتصاب هي ماشي شي حاجه اللي
متعلقه اغتصاب وحده هو في تسليع المراه
اننا كنعتبرها كضاعه ولابد الرجل يحميها
الاب ديالها يحميها ومن بعد خاصنا نقلبوا
لها على رجل واحد اخر اللي خصو يحميها فيه
المبررات اللي كنلقاو للرجل اننا دائما
شكرا دائما
اريد ان اختم هنا مع جميع الضيوف باختصار
سابدا معك زينه رحيم البحث ربما البحث يجب
ان يكون عن فك مفهوم الشرف في عقول الناس
عن النساء او عم بين الرجلين لدى النساء
اليس اليس هذا ما يمكن ان يسلم ربما بكسر
هذه الثقافه بتخطي حاجز الصمت بتغيير
المفاهيم السائده
ب ناخذ الاشياء بشكل حرفي ما عدا الشرف
فقط نربطها بالنساء رغم ان مفهوم الحرفي
هو الاستقامه هو الاشياء الايجابيه التي
يمكن ان يقوم بها الاشخاص بالتاكيد عدم
تسليع النساء كما تم ذكره فك ارتباطها مع
الشرف كسر دائره العنف عدم تقبل التحرش
كهضمه او كشيء مثير الاعمال الفنيه
الاغاني وكل الاشياء التي تشجع وتطبع مع
العنف ومع تسليع النساء هي تساهم برفض
ثقافه الاغتصاب وتؤدي بالنتيجه لافلات
المقتصدين من العقاب شكرا لك زينه رولا
كلمه اخيره لو سمحتي بالنسبه للاغتصاب هو
طبعا مرفوض بكل الاشكال وضروره جدا انه
نسمع للطرفين
للمدعيه
للمتهم لحتى ما نكون كمان عم نظلم ناس
ابرياء شغله كتير مهمه لها علاقه بالشرف
لما نطلع نحن من هذا المفهوم انه شرف
المراه هو مرتبط بين عفوا
بين الرجلين ساعتها بنقدر بيتمكنوا النساء
من انه ما يخافوا او ما يخجلوا انه يحكوا
عن جرائم اغتصاب تعرضوا لالها بس شرط انه
ما تكون اتهامات زور تكون اتهامات حقيقيه
لو سمحت
[موسيقى]
مثل نظريات شبه علميه انه
يوقف حاله واذا خاطئه جدا يعني
[موسيقى]
مش حتى حيوانيه لان حتى الحيوانات
حتى الحيوانات ما بيعملوا
بالثقافه تبعنا انه الرجل دائما بده دائما
بينط وما بيقدر يتحكم على حاله انه هدول
كلهم مفاهيم لازم نفكهم كمان
اتمنى ان نصل الى يوم حيث يكمل الشرف ليس
فيما يجود بين الرجلين بل في صيانه الحقوق
والمساواه اكثر من ذلك واللي تكون
المساواه بين الرجل والمراه كامله على
الرجل ان يشتغل اكثر
له نترك لك ولك حريه التفكير وحريات
الاختيار ابقى دائما على تحياتي
[موسيقى]